pour terminer cette édition spéciale sur
tv fils focus à présent sur la 11e
circonscription des yvelines avec vous
haussmann et cette confirmation ce matin
à notre micro benoît hamon sera bien
candidat à l'élection législative
et oui le malheureux candidat du parti
socialiste à arrivé cinquième au premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle avec
6,36 % des voix et donc candidat à sa
réélection sur la 11e circonscription et
il n'aura pas la tâche facile en il faut
le savoir dans son fief attrape le
candidat est arrivé deuxième avec 24,23
% au premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle devancé par jean luc
mélenchon à prendre deux points 62
malgré cela le candidat se dit confiant
et mettra en avant ses actions sur la
circonscription
ils me connaissent bien ils savent que
je suis un homme honnête loyal très
engagé j'ai beaucoup travaillé pour
cette circonscription pour tout le
canton de saint cyr comme le canton de
trappes elancourt le mesnil là derrière
j'ai travaillé pour ce canton pour les
habitants de ce canton et de cette
circonscription
c'est à temps pour laquelle je me
représente avec beaucoup d'enthousiasmé
et beaucoup de force et de la force il
lui en faudra le maire d'elancourt jean
michel fourgous souhaite lui aussi
conquérir le siège de député un poste
que le candidat investi par les
républicains a bien connu en effet il a
été député de la 11e de 1995 à 2002 et
de 2007 à 2012 avant de perdre face à
benoît hamon jean michel fourgous veut
mettre l'accent sur l'emploi la sécurité
et l'éducation pour lui le bilan de
benoît hamon c'est je cite plus de
chômeurs et le fiasco des nouveaux
rythmes scolaires
ambiance jean michel fourgous qui n'a
pas souhaité aujourd'hui s'exprimer
devant nos caméras il attend à les
consignes une recommandation de sa
formation politique et il y en ad'autres
un des candidats sur sept et 11e
circonscription il y a tout d'abord la
candidate du front national mathilde de
andrew hayes c'est la première fois que
la conseillère régionale ile-de-france
du fn se présentent sur 7 certes
inscriptions même si marine le pen n'a
fait que 20 24 ans 11% des bois dans ce
conte dans ce canton
contre 79,9 % pour emmanuel macron la
candidate compte bien profiter de
l'effet présidentielle écoutez la fia
qui s'est vraiment pouvoir c'est la
continuation de l'élection
présidentielle dans le sens où là on est
dans une élection nationale et on aurait
tort de s'arrêter au juste vos
considérations locales
le but du jeu étant de pour nous de
former cette réelle opposition qui s'est
incarné hier ford enfin dans ce face à
face
donc oui le but du jeu étant de montrer
que le camp des patriotes est là et bien
présent et est la seule véritable
opposition à monsieur macro noter que
sur cette circonscription c'est à saint
cyr que le front national fait son
meilleur score avec 23 points 66 % des
voix autres candidats qui devraient être
investis dans les prochains jours silvia
quandt albi pour debout la france
la présidente d'honneur du parti dans
les yvelines n'en n'est pas à son
premier essai elle s'était déjà présenté
en 2012 et avait récolté 0 68% des
boîtes merci haussmann est on